today on the matt well show dr fauci is
coming under fire from both the left and
the right and what is it that has
finally made the public turn on him the
answer to that question tells us quite a
bit about our culture and its priorities
also a virginia court rules that a girl
was in fact raped inside a bathroom in a
loudoun county school but the media
still isn't ready to accept the story
fully in fact they're now engaging in
what in any other circumstance would be
called victim blaming and a gop senate
candidate says that he doesn't believe
in the separation of church and state
he's getting criticism for that but he
has a point plus the republican
candidate for governor of virginia is
surging in the polls after leaning into
cultural and social issues might the
republican party finally learn a
valuable lesson from that we'll talk
about all that and more on the matt
walsh show
it was revealed some months ago that the
national institute of allergy and
infectious disease under the leadership
of falchi spent hundreds of thousands of
dollars funding experiments in which
aborted babies at 20 weeks gestation
were chopped into pieces and little bits
of them were then grafted onto rodents
to create as it is described by the
researchers humanized mice
this really happened the mice with baby
scalps attached to them were monitored
for weeks in an effort to learn more
about infectious diseases and cancer
and whatever else
now there's a very good chance that you
never heard about those experiments at
all but whether you did or didn't it can
it can't be said that there was little
public outcry over it there was no
public outcry there was certainly no
bipartisan outrage about it
just as there's been um
no bipartisan outrage there's been
outrage but no bipartisan outrage over
the fact that fauci's nih funded virus
research in wuhan something that the
national institute of health finally
admitted this week after months of
denial from fauci personally
in front of congress in many sessions
arguing back and forth with uh with rand
paul
saying this didn't happen now they admit
that it did
that's to say nothing of fouchy's
incompetence indifference and political
gamesmanship during the pandemic the
pandemic that his institution may
partially be responsible for in the
first place i mean overall fauci has
shown an utterly callous disregard for
human life and human suffering he has
special contempt for life at its most
vulnerable stages in the womb which is
also why he went running to the world
health organization a day after biden's
inauguration to triumphantly announce
that the mexico city policy banning
funding of abortion overseas would be
lifted i mean he couldn't wait for that
to happen
this is the kind of man that fouchy is
a soulless bureaucrat a shill
who feels no guilt for the blood on his
hands and there's a substantial amount
of human blood on his hands
but in spite of the moral crimes i just
listed and perhaps partially because of
them
fauci has been as you've noticed
not only led off the hook but hailed as
a hero much like andrew cuomo was in the
early months of the pandemic you recall
that cuomo was so widely acclaimed that
people on the left were proudly
declaring themselves cuomo sexual
even as the then governor consigned
thousands of elderly people to their
deaths by locking them in nursing homes
with coveted positive patients
that didn't hurt his reputation at all
until it came out that cuomo along with
being a serial killer of the elderly
also made inappropriate comments to
women
you know the mass graves of grandmas and
grandpas those were tolerable but
flirtatious remarks to women were not
and so cuomo was summarily knocked off
of his perch and then right out of the
governor's mansion
perhaps fauci may face a similar fate as
this week for the first time in his
career
he's been the target of negative
headlines in the corporate media
and we're told bipartisan outrage
not because little babies were chopped
into pieces and stitched onto rats
not because the nih funded research in
wuhan not because of the thousands dead
due to incompetence and malice from our
public health expert class including
fauci
but because some dogs were mistreated
here's our local fox 17 in nashville
with the story it says a tennessee
congressman is among 23 other federal
lawmakers bipartisan group to sign a
letter calling on dr anthony fauci and
the national institutes of health to
respond to reports on the testing and
killing of puppies in the name of
science
the issue centers around a report from
the animal advocacy group and taxpayer
watchdog white coat waste project which
as previously reported on puppy testing
specifically beagles
wcwp reports this is the fourth time
they've uncovered inhumane practices on
beagle puppies funded by the national
institute of allergy and infectious
diseases a part of the nih which dr
faushi heads the report states that the
niaid
spent 1.6 million dollars in taxpayer
funds to poison and debark
44 beagle puppies force-feeding the
puppies an experimental drug cutting
their vocal cords
and then killing and dissecting them the
cutting of the vocal cords known as
debarking is opposed by the humane
society of the united states and the
american veterinary medical association
or a procedure that the wcwp calls a
pain painful and cruel
adding that their fundings were a result
of a freedom of their findings rather a
result of a freedom of information act
request saying the studies on beagles
were unnecessary as the drug being
studied had already been extensively
tested and confirmed on different
animals
okay and peta has of course come out
strongly as expected as well even though
peta kills dogs all the time so they
shouldn't have an issue here
as mentioned the lawmakers demanding
answers from valjey are bipartisan
marking the first time that the phrase
bipartisan lawmakers and demand answers
from fauci can be used in a sentence
together
in another first there have been actual
critical headlines about voucher in
mainstream news sites
and the criticism is warranted of course
it sounds like the beagle experiments
were unnecessary and cruel
even if the ultimate goal was to develop
medical treatments that might benefit
human beings
i mean i would rather if you got to test
this stuff i'd rather be tested on
animals not people
but
even so
sounds like it's a very cruel and
terrible experiment
and yet
dogs are not people
puppies are not babies
not human babies anyway
there is nothing you could do to a puppy
that would be worse than scalping an
infant
which is what they did in those other
experiments that nobody cared about
they scalped
infants now i am welcoming of an
of any warranted criticism fauci
receives
and if this is ultimately the thing that
leads to him to resign in disgrace much
like cuomo i don't know if that will
happen or not
but if it does i'll be happy to see him
go
but at a certain point we have to stand
back and and assess our priorities
and figure out how we ended up in a
culture where tortured puppies attract
more outrage than tortured babies
i mean this isn't this is not a what
about thing
it's not what about isn't because i'm
not trying to
change the subject from from uh from
these experiments what i'm trying to do
is talk about priorities
and the fact that we
and i speak in general terms when i say
we
value the lives of dogs over the lives
of our fellow human beings
we practice the weirdest form of pagan
animal worship
in this country that the world has ever
seen
it's not based in mythology like other
cultures unless we count all the
anthropomorphizing disney movies that we
grew up watching and i do think actually
that has something to do with it
um and there are no standard religious
practices surrounding it
we've come to our animal worship not
from a position of religious fervor
necessarily but more from a place of
despair and indifference
we don't recognize the inherent worth
and dignity in human beings anymore
so we've elevated dogs to take that
place instead
this is something so pervasive
that you hear it even from conservatives
this unfortunately i wish i could say
this is a left versus right there's
another left versus right um paradigm
here but it's not
i hear from self-professed conservatives
all the time saying in fact proudly
saying openly saying yeah i i i value
dogs more than people i care about my
dog more than i care about most people
this is and you're a conservative
saying that you value human life below
dogs and you think that that you can
qualify as a conservative what exactly
do you think you're conserving here
i thought one of the most fundamental
things we're conserving is the dignity
and moral worth of human life
and if you're putting dogs above people
then you're not conserving that and
you're not on my side
i don't know whose side you think you're
on
and this is something we don't want to
talk about this it's something nobody
wants to talk about i mean i've been
talking about it for for years
there is something
and i know it's difficult for a lot of
people
because our because of our attachment to
dogs and no one is saying that we
shouldn't have pet dogs as pets so we
shouldn't care about our dogs
but if you notice something within
yourself where you value the lives of
dogs over people
then that is a deep sickness in your
soul
that you need to try to fix
because
this this we cannot have a society like
this
or this even needs to be a discussion
where it can come out that they were
chopping babies into pieces
and nobody cares until they say oh yeah
they also did it to dogs
our priorities
are massively out of a line
and we need to get them straight
now let's get to our five headlines well
as an increasing number of companies
fall over themselves trying to appeal to
the left wouldn't it be nice to find one
company just one that supports your
values well here's one charity mobile is
the pro-life phone company they partner
with you to automatically support the
pro-life pro-family charity of your
choice with five percent of your monthly
plan price and uh they've sent millions
of dollars to charities so far and done
a lot of good in the world because of it
but there's a lot of other great perks
that you get as a customer new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping when you mention offer
code walsh and it's really easy to
switch if you're worried about the
hassle of switching uh
carriers it's easy to do you can keep
your existing phone number and you may
even be able to keep your existing phone
on top of it if you need a new phone
well no problem charity mobile has a
variety of options from basic flip
phones and low-cost smartphones to the
latest 5g phones monthly plan prices
have just been lowered again as well and
now you can add even more lines to
family plans so switch charity mobile
right now and support causes you care
about call them at 1-877-474
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com and mention offer code
walsh
[Music]
you know there's some there's just
one other note on the dog thing
um
there is there the other thing about it
the other the other factor here that
plays into it i think there is
the fact that a lot of people value dog
life over human life that's that's
that's the big that's the big story here
um but also
because we tend to be pretty shallow and
and um
and uh we we have difficulty following
stories that are a little bit more
complicated when there's an image
attached to the story
it's going to get a lot more attention
it shouldn't be that way
you know you shouldn't need the image
you shouldn't need the photograph if
someone tells you that something
happened and you know that it happened
that it's true that it happened like the
experiments they did
with um quote-unquote fetal tissue
there's there's no denying that that
happened it's just we don't have any
images of it
with the with the dog experiments there
is one image of the dogs with their
heads in the in the glass boxes where
they're being eaten alive by sand fleas
i guess
and there's an image of that and so that
that is another factor that plays into
it
but that doesn't justify the discrepancy
that also speaks to our
shallowness
um as as people
all right
let's uh
move on to another issue that we that we
should all care about and at least most
of us on the on
most of us seem to care about at least
on the right anyway this should be
another thing that's bipartisan from the
daily wire it says a virginia court
ruled monday that there is enough
evidence to find
that a teen accused of sexually
assaulting a fellow student at loudoun
county high school bathroom in may
engaged in non-consensual sex i.e it was
a rape the daily wire broke the story of
the sexual assault in lounge county last
month
uh bringing to light two alleged rapes
at two separate schools one of which
involves scott smith's daughter smith
was later arrested at aladdin county
school board meeting so we know about
that
the teen who appeared in court on monday
is standing trial in two separate cases
so
we finally have an official confirmation
of that as well because we heard about
the second rape and it wasn't officially
confirmed
that it was by the same student but now
that's official as well
one involving a student at stonebridge
high school and a different incident in
a classroom at broad run high school
both in the loudoun county school
district so
there was a girl raped in a bathroom
and then that the rapist is sent to a
different school
where he then rapes a stude a
fellow student in a classroom this time
the teen who reportedly identifies as
gender fluid is alleged to have
assaulted scott miss scott smith's
daughter in a girl's restroom at
stonebridge while wearing a skirt
um despite indications that he had
committed a serious crime the boy was
was then transferred
so
this is this is confirmation the rape
did occur
um we know that the cover-up happened
too
we have absolute confirmation of that
we know that it happened because we have
the loudoun county school board on
record we have the superintendent on
record
saying that they had no information of
any assaults happening in bathrooms
when we know that they did we know that
they were told about it so we know they
lied there was absolutely a cover-up no
question about it we don't have to say
alleged
we don't have to say alleged about the
rape either now
these are things that happened
so what's the media going to do um
they've tried ignoring this they can't
fully ignore it because we have we have
forced them to acknowledge it
and so now they are retreating to
what in any other circumstance they
would call victim blaming so here is
justin juvenal
who's a reporter um
calls himself a justice reporter
ironically enough
for the washington post and he he posted
he said a teen testified she met a
classmate for consensual sex in the
girls bathroom of a loudoun county high
school before
but in a may encounter she was sexually
assaulted
new details in the case of the center
for firestorm
now even that detail
that according to the washington post
this teen girl
had a previous um
had previous sexual encounters previous
consensual sexual encounters with this
boy
but in this case it was not consensual
now adding in that detail
especially making it sort of a headline
justin here posted it on twitter making
it kind of the headline
in any other circumstance
that would be called victim blaming
and for good reason actually because
what what what difference does that make
what does it have to do with anything
because because in the past she's she'd
had consensual encounters with this
yeah this what 14 year old girl had had
consensual 14 or 15 year old years old
had consensual encounters with this boy
that means what does that mean it
doesn't mean anything at all
the fact is she did not consent in this
case and so that's rape
but there is
given what's at stake here as far as the
left and the media is concerned
you know there's there's
it's really two levels
first of all this is about assaults in
public school
and a public school cover-up
something that
as we've talked about on this show is
endemic in the public school system
there is a there is a real sexual
assault
epidemic a crisis in the school system
and there has been for decades
and before we ever
injected any of the gender ideology
aspects into any of these stories the
media had no interest in talking about
it
because it's the public school system if
we're going to talk about
epidemics of sexual assault they much
you know they're fine talking about it
in hollywood even though hollywood is
left-wing they certainly would would
like talking about it in in the catholic
church
but not in the public school system
so already they're pre-predisposed to
ignore these cases and then you add in
the fact
that this kid is gender non-conforming
this happened in a bathroom
at a time when the school board was
pushing through a policy to open up the
bathrooms for boys and girls to share
together
you add in that and um
there is no level they won't to which
they will not stoop
to include victim blaming
all right
this is from cnbc as the media continues
its war on facebook
it says the facebook papers a series of
articles published by a consortium
uh of 17 u.s news outlets beginning
friday shed new light on the company's
thinking behind its actions leading up
to the capital insurrection quote
unquote on january 6th and its ability
to fend off hate speech in languages
outside of english
facebook shares vacillated between
slightly negative slightly positive
monday after the news outlets published
their stories based on the leaked
documents so now we've got uh 17 outlets
coming together to dump all the
information that they have all all of
the dirty little secrets about facebook
cnn in fact
had a segment
this morning about facebook
where they're talking about the
quote-unquote damning allegations and at
a certain point they scroll a kind of
star wars
scroll of all of the crimes and high
crimes and misdemeanors committed by
facebook let's uh let's watch that
the following are accusations
revelations or admissions of what
facebook and its branches are doing to
the world
told not in the words of facebook's
outside critics but critics from the
inside that it is a platform for
spreading of hate speech that it is ripe
for abuse by those who wish to do harm
that it is a petri dish for poisonous
misinformation that it has opened the
floodgates to conspiracy theories that
cost lives it's a safe haven for
politicians to lie a marketplace for
trafficking and for selling human beings
and it's especially damaging to the
self-esteem of young girls that provided
some of the fuel for the capital
insurrection an empowerment vehicle for
extremists at home and abroad and has a
different standard for safety based on
the country in which you live and much
of this hasn't been or can't be stopped
facebook has not or cannot sufficiently
police itself critics say misleading
investors along the way and perhaps most
damning of all is that the company is
accused of knowing so much of this but
doing so little to stop it instead
whistleblowers show facebook has and
continues to prioritize growth over
safety and profit over people
uh
the thing that continues to be so funny
about this facebook story from the media
is that
there is a scandal with facebook and
with big tech and all big social media
sites
which is
the way that they censor
and find ways to undermine and minimize
and negate conservative content
these are all of them
intensely left-leaning
uh
companies
run entirely by people on the far left
there's no one in any position of
significant leadership at any of these
companies
that could at all be described as
right-wing they would have been they
would they would have been tossed out
long ago they never would have made it
to that position in the first place
so there there's there are real scandals
there are real things that could be
uncovered
but cnn and the new in the washington
post and new york times and the
corporate media
they have no interest in any of that in
fact they're trying to make the opposite
case about about about facebook and and
even twitter now
uh there was a there was a story from
one of these corporate media outlets
about how on twitter big scandal
turns out that uh there are some
right-wing
accounts on twitter that get more
engagement than left-wing accounts
i mean they're actually trying to claim
i'm actually trying to claim that there
is a
pro-right-wing bias
on facebook and and on twitter
but that's again always staying on on
the offense
no they're not going to be on defense
and defend themselves
or or you know defend facebook and
twitter from claims of
of
anti-right bias or pro no they're going
to go all the way to the other other end
and say no actually these these sites
are are pro right-wing
that's how you're getting so much
engagement
yeah there are accounts on facebook and
twitter that get a lot of engagement and
are on the right but that is in spite of
everything these companies have done to
minimize
us why do we still get that engagement
well maybe because our content is
engaging
because people are interested in it
so they don't but they don't want to
talk about that that's that's the one
real scandal they can't talk about it so
they're grasping at straws to find
something else
and uh
there's just nothing there i mean i've
read through
yet 17 corporate media outlets
releasing this major report about all
the things they discovered about
facebook
just like the facebook whistleblower
testifying in front of congress i've
listened to all of that i've read all
the reports
and there's this there's simply nothing
the headline is just that is facebook
values profits
whoa had no idea
and also also that it's not particularly
good for people no matter where you fall
on the political spectrum to spend a lot
of time on social media and that's
especially true for our kids
another another stunning revelation
but outside of that they've they there's
really there's
they've they have dug up nothing they've
been digging and digging and they've dug
up nothing because
what they could be digging up is over
there it's the other side of the field
but they're they're digging holes over
here where the uh skeletons aren't
buried
all right here's a tweet from ora bogato
media person
in reaction to alec baldwin's statement
about the shooting where um
you know he releases a statement
about
uh the shooting on this though on the
set of his film and he calls the victim
a wife mother and colleague
which is what she was
ora begatto says
helena hutchins was a person in and of
herself she was a cinematographer she
was a professional for men women
for men women continue to exist only in
reference to men it's patriarchal it's
violent and in this particular case it
feels especially disgusting
so for ora bogato
this is what she's upset at alec baldwin
for not for shooting the poor woman and
killing her
but for after the fact describing her as
a wife
this is patriarchal apparently
meanwhile you know the funny thing is
she said well don't describe her as a
wife
um describe her as a professional
describe her as a you know cinematic
cinematographer
but that also if you describe people in
terms of what they do for a living
you're still describing them based on
their relationship to other people
and that's how that's how we are all
defined that's how we all define
ourselves
none of us define ourselves in a vacuum
we define ourselves by our relationship
with and to other people
and for almost everyone fundamentally
the relationships that matter most of
them it's it's not at work it's not
their profession
it's their family their spouses their
kids
um
but for feminists they they find this
very upsetting
even though it's it's it is fundamental
and basic to human nature
you really you can't describe anyone in
a in a vacuum i mean try doing that try
try describing someone in a meaningful
way
without making any reference to their
relationships to other people
impossible to do
uh next we have josh mandel he's a
senate candidate in ohio and he caused a
little bit of a stir online he was
trending online for a while
because of what he said about
the separation of church and state let's
play that first
left
the
fake news media
the yuna party in washington they're
trying to take god out of all aspects of
society
and they're trying to
water down on the judeo-christian
bedrock of america and my personal
feeling is
we shouldn't be watering down we should
be doubling down we should be instilling
faith in the classroom
in the workplace
and everywhere in society the secular
left the aclu the southern poverty law
center a lot of these soros funded
organizations
they
they advance the argument that the
separation of church and state
exists and for that reason you can't
teach kids about religion
my personal feeling is there's no such
thing as separation of church and state
the framers of the constitution
envisioned a country where in the
classroom kids would learn about god
that in the classroom kids would learn
about good versus evil and that
judeo-christian ethic separates itself
from islam and atheism and all these
other belief sets on so many levels but
one of the main levels is our
acknowledgment of good versus evil
uh yeah
of course there's nothing you can do
that's more short to cause outrage these
days than than to speak basic comments
that's everything you said there was
basic comments and also historically
accurate of course the separation of
church and state
uh should it should be it should be
widely known and understood the
separation of church and state is not in
the constitution that was in a letter
written by thomas jefferson and in fact
um
and usually letters written by political
figures don't carry any kind of legal
weight at least they shouldn't
but his concern in the letter was not
with religion's effect on government but
with government effects government's
effect on religion and that's why he was
talking about the need for a separation
of church and state
but he's correct in the clip there that
you can't really no matter what
the supreme court says no matter what we
claim
you can't actually separate
uh church and state in that way
especially not in a classroom especially
not an educational context
because a person's
religious views
you know if they're if they're in charge
of education if they're in charge of
teaching
their religious views are always going
to come through
there's always going to be a value
system attached
to the education
not not simply attached like some sort
of accessory but the education is going
to come in the context of a value system
that's always going to be true
there's no way of getting around that
which is why i'm always saying you know
we can't
it's easy to talk about how we don't
want our kids to be indoctrinated
but that's not actually
the issue here
the issue is not that our kids are being
indoctrinated period
it's the way that they're being
indoctrinated and who's doing the
indoctrination
and what they're being indoctrinated
into
but indoctrination simply means
instilling values
it means passing on a belief system a
worldview
which is as parents of course we want to
do that with our kids so yes i want to
indoctrinate my kids all parents do
whether they use the word or not
um
and that's going to be the case in the
school system no matter what
and yes right now in the school system
it is very much a religious environment
when i was
at the nashville public school board
meeting
talking about masks
there were religious icons all plastered
all over the room
people were wearing them
except the religious icon it was they
weren't crucifixes
it was uh gay pride flags
that for the left is a religious icon
it's part of their religion whether they
call it that or not
critical race theory gender ideology all
of this
these are not
just religious views these are intensely
religious
views gender ideology
there's there's nothing else you can
call that i mean the belief that
a boy
or a man can
somehow in some mysterious and mystical
way can really be a woman you know you
can have the essence of a woman trapped
inside him
this doesn't make any sense on any level
but if you want to even begin begin to
make sense of it
you have to engage with it on a
spiritual level
this is a spiritual religious claim
so all that is true you're going to have
that in the classroom no matter what
it's just a matter of what the what the
value systems are what the religious
views are
now with all that said
um
what would i actually want
public school teachers
to be teaching
the christian
religion
well the answer there is no because i
wouldn't trust them to do it
you know i say i say the same thing with
uh with sex ed
but there's always the argument about do
we want uh
should it be com so-called comprehensive
sex ed or should it be
abstinence
first sex ed
and usually conservatives say oh no i
want teachers teaching abstinence
yeah that's that's better than the
so-called comprehensive sex ed but i
don't really want that either because i
don't i don't trust the teachers to do
that correctly i don't i don't trust
them
to impart you know to kind of make the
moral case
for
uh
saving yourself for marriage i don't
trust them to do that
that's a very important and delicate
message and i wouldn't trust government
employees with it
so all this goes back to
homeschool that's really the answer
all right uh
let's see i also wanted to mention this
this is from bloomberg it says a
virginia museum is proposing to melt
down a statue of confederate general
robert e lee that was the focus of a
violent white nationalist rally in 2017
in charlottesville and create a new work
of public art
the jefferson school african american
heritage center submitted its proposal
last week to charlottesville city
council and city manager it outlines a
plan to create the new work of art
through a community engagement process
and then give it to the city to be
installed on public land
so you see the progression here
first it was okay we just want to take
down a few confederate statues
and then it was okay actually we want to
take all of them down but that'll be it
that'll be the end of it we promise
and then it was actually all right we
want to take down all the confederate
statues but and also columbus and he's
coming down too but that'll be it
and then it was never mind yeah we got
to tear down the the uh the founders too
sorry they
they got to come down sorry tj he's got
to go down too
but but don't worry it'll all go to a
museum
and then finally now we're told hey
funny story the museum is going to melt
down the the museums where we said we're
going to send all this stuff because
it's not a war on history we're just
sending it to museum that's all
but funny story um in fact the museum is
going to melt the statues down
and turn them into a sculpture of george
floyd riding a unicorn to heaven
and of course at each step
along the way
idiots
on the right have said well okay as long
as this is it
the whole claim that they're that
they're going to take all these
sculptures
which they say are were are hateful and
bigoted
and they're going to respectfully store
them
and put them on display in a museum i
mean if you believe that i don't know
what to tell you
that was never going to be the case
most of these things they've taken down
and said are going to museums but some
of them have already been destroyed most
of them are just in a warehouse
somewhere
um and and uh we'll never see the light
of day or will be destroyed
and we talk about how this is a war on
history which it is
but it's also
important to point out that this is um
not only a war on history
it's part of our culture's continued war
on on beauty
because it's not irrelevant
that many of the statues that have been
taken out including this robert e lee
one
these are
whatever you think of the subject
these are beautiful works of art
that were made by by real artists
decades and you know over a century ago
in this case
um
and we're destroying
beautiful works of art
to replace them with you know god knows
what
god knows what they're going to come up
with in place of that
all right uh finally i'm afraid i have
to play this as much as it pains me ben
shapiro
is back on the college circuit again
doing yaf events which is great
but during the q a event um
one of our courageous brothers one of
our comrades from the sweet baby gang
was generous enough
this was an act of generosity and we in
the sweet baby gang are very generous
and so he was generous enough to offer
ben an opportunity to pledge his undying
loyalty to the gang
and ben was uh i have to say
not gracious in his response listen
one more question
would i be able to get you right here
right now to pledge your undying
allegiance to matt walsh's sweet baby
gang
[Music]
no okay
reprehensible
not even worthy of an explanation
says benj let's be honest about what
this is gang uh ben
shapiro has declared war
on the sweet baby gang
and because
anyone who does not swear fealty to the
sweet baby gang is our enemy we all
understand that
you're either in the gang or you're not
and if you're not then you're an enemy
and an existential threat to our
existence
that's the side that uh ben shapiro has
chosen and he will rue the day
rue the day
next time i see him here in the office
i'm gonna
i'm not gonna say anything but i will
think you have no idea the kinds of
things i'll be thinking
although i do when i listen to that clip
i did like the fact that uh he mentioned
the sweet baby gang and the crowd you
know i was kind of expecting the crowd
just there to be a confused silence in
the crowd like what
but no the sweet this this is the this
is how fast the sweet baby gang has
grown
this is how our movement is growing
everyone in that crowd knew exactly they
were all members of the gang
all right
let's uh
speaking of which let's read the
comments
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
jay moran says i grew up without either
parent and was subsequently raised by my
grandparents whom i called mom and dad
now that i'm married and have two boys
of my own i can attest that everything
matt said about fathers and the
parenting dynamic between the parents
is absolutely 100 correct
uh yeah i
this
that's because it's we we can all attest
to to that fact
uh whether we had a father growing up
you know if you if you had an attentive
father growing up
then you know how valuable fathers are
and if you didn't then you know even
more how valuable fathers are
but
at least temporarily the media finally
discovered it yesterday as we talked
about
um
bad house media says i do love how
genuinely angry matt gets when he talks
about what's happening to kids his
concern and real anger towards the left
is really inspiring
well i'm not the only one i mean this is
this is something that
i think and we'll i don't want to give
it all away because we're going to talk
about this in the daily cancellation but
this is something that that does provoke
and should provoke
real anger in in all of us as parents
when we see what's happening to to our
kids
jake williams says an astronaut with a
sword is clearly a jedi
matt
no i mean a jedi is even more useless
than that so
i i didn't watch star wars as a kid
and if i if i had watched it
i would not have gone trick-or-treating
as a jedi
one of my many problems with star wars
is that massive hole in the story of
you've got these what
first of all this this is happening
i guess it's happening long long ago in
a galaxy far away but it's still you
know they have futuristic technology
anyone
any old person like the the the star
wars equivalent of a middle-class
lower-class person can buy a spaceship
at a at a second-hand store that that
goes the speed of light
and then you've got jedis
who also on top of have magical powers
and their weapon of choice is a laser
sword
that has never made any sense to me
um
danny says matt's parents only told him
that the candy was poisoned so that they
could eat it why that is something that
i figured out only much much later in
life that i figured that out but i i've
realized that now
ed proctor says
dear god matt has a view of what
marriage is that dates back to the
caveman
i feel sorry for his wife not to mention
his poor kids
yeah i mean i it's it is it's a caveman
view
how dare i
how embarrassing and shameful of me
that you know i have the same view of
marriage that
almost every man in the country does
that we would like to share a name with
our wives
this is
yet another example of something that
you know i can say that provokes all
this outrage meanwhile almost everyone
agrees
almost every man
in america
would strongly prefer
when they do get married their wives
share their names and they and if
they're not married yet they would
strongly prefer it
um
and in fact this is a is a tradition
that goes back i think about a thousand
years
but ed if you want if you want to say it
goes back all the way to caveman times
i'll take that too that makes it an even
more timeless tradition even more reason
to respect it
um
ryan says this isn't the first time i've
heard you reference the crucible and i'm
all and i for when i'm all for it do you
think with the full lobby of the sweet
baby gang dilly wire might look into the
rights to stream it yeah i don't know
about that but i do think the crucible
you know that to me is sort of like my
the way that that people reference 1984
all the time
uh yeah i guess i i reference the
crucible especially in our cancer in our
in our canceled culture
i think that there are a lot of
important parallels
to the crucible
uh
and uh let's see what else we got here
finally light brand says i'm with matt
on his excellent explanation of name and
unity yet matt's answer as to why we
should keep the man's name rather than
the woman's is because it's tradition
i was hoping for a more profound reason
in going behind the merit of it all and
why said tradition is correct but after
five minutes of babble it's still it's
tradition and we shouldn't change it
without good reason because our
forefathers did it and we and we're
inheriting it so don't question it
uh well i did give
the reason behind it which is that the
the man is supposed to be
the head of the home and the leader in
the home
which is what i which is what i believe
um so that's the reason
um
or at least that's one of the
significant reasons
but see you're you're you're showing the
same attitude to tradition that's very
common on the left very common in our
culture today generally
that you know if it's if it's just a
tradition then we might as well throw it
out even if we don't know why it was
there even if we have no reason to throw
it out
a thousand-year-old tradition ah just
dispense of it
because you don't see any value in
tradition itself
that's certainly not a conservative view
i could tell you that
that's another thing we talk about what
we're trying to conserve as
conservatives i would think that's
that's another of the big the big ones
trying to conserve our cultural
traditions
uh all right let's get now to our daily
cancellation i want to take a second to
tell you again about our friends over 40
days for life and their new book what to
say when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion uh people tend to
get a little bit nervous when the
subject of abortion comes up and there's
no reason for that if you're if you're
at least if you're a pro-lifer there's
no reason to be nervous because you have
all the truth on your side we have truth
and what is right on our side which is
which is a great advantage in any
discussion but the problem is how do you
sift through all of the nonsense that's
thrown at you by the pro-abortion side
well this book which is uh has been a
number one amazon new release and a
number two amazon bestseller will tell
you exactly how to do that this book is
incredibly easy to use it tells you what
to say what not to say and it's proven
arguments that have worked with
everybody people on the fence abortion
supporters even planned parenthood
workers have found these arguments
compelling 40 days for life is the
largest grassroots pro-life organization
in the world they've held peaceful
vigils outside abortion facilities in 1
000 cities and 64 countries and it
helped convert the hearts of 221
abortion workers and counting so you
know you can trust them just go now to
amazon or get it directly from 40 days
for life at 40daysforlife.com
and also there's no better way to wake
up than with your once daily dose of the
facts that's why the daily wire created
morningwire the daily morning show
dedicated to bringing you all the news
you need to know without any spin or
hidden agenda it's the only daily
podcast that values your time and the
truth and while we're working overtime
to make sure
fact-based news still has a platform we
need your help to keep the facts
trending towards number one so subscribe
and start listening now to morning wire
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts and leave a five star review
if you like what you hear now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
the virginia's governor's race will be
decided in a week from today most
pundits and prognosticators thought it
had already been decided months ago
coming off a presidential election where
biden carried the state by 10 points
and with at the time the democrat
challenged terry mcauliffe leading in
the polls by a healthy margin but things
have changed and now republican glenn
youngkin is tied neck and neck with
mcauliffe in a race that was never
supposed to be close at all
and all the momentum is on his side as
well youngkin is doing something that
republicans are very rarely able to do
he's dictating the terms
of the race he's deciding what the main
issues are donald trump was always good
at that he was good at dictating terms
in this way few other republicans have
been able to do the same but that's
what's happening right now in virginia
that's what barack obama was railing
against when he showed up to a stump for
mcauliffe yesterday whining that
republicans
were focusing on phony culture war
issues here's that clip again
we don't have time
to be
wasting
on these phony trumped-up culture wars
this fake outrage
that right-wing media's pedals to juice
their ratings and the fact that he's
willing to go along with it instead of
talking about serious problems that
actually affect serious people
that's a shame
that's not what this election is about
that's not what you need virginia
instead of forcing our communities to
cut back at a time when we're just
starting to recover we should be doing
more to support people who are educating
our kids and keeping our neighborhoods
safe
[Applause]
of course this is a riseable claim
coming from obama complaining about fake
outrages after his side just had a
month-long psychotic meltdown over a
stand-up comedy special i mean these are
the people who made headline news out of
an nfl coach's vulgar emails a decade
ago they turned a high school kid into a
national villain because he smiled at a
native american guy in dc
fake outrages are their specialty it's
what they do
and yet obama is not entirely wrong and
we would make a mistake to entirely
dismiss his point
he's wrong when he uses words like phony
but he's right
that the governor's race of virginia has
become centered around the culture war
it has indeed become a cultural fight
and that's worked out well for the
republican in the race
junkin who began his campaign as a kind
of standard factory-issued gop guy
has in the last several weeks moved away
from that mold and leaned into
the social and cultural issues and
that's largely why he's now surging
whether he wins or loses next week this
is a point that republicans at all
levels everywhere in the country need to
absorb it's also a point that i've been
screaming for years
contrary to the faux wisdom of the
establishment you don't win elections by
speaking to people exclusively through
their wallets
you're not going to motivate masses of
voters to flock to the polls because you
have a tax plan that's moderately better
than the other dude
no you speak to people through their
hearts their souls
by connecting with what they value even
more than money or financial security
i mean the march for life
um has attracted a million a half a
million people annually to dc for four
decades
no other movement in the history of the
country has ever been able to do
anything like that
because the pro-life movement is
animated by its determination to protect
the dignity and worth of human life
our belief in the dignity of worth of
human life is fundamental
it gets down to the core of who we are
i believe strongly that taxes should be
lowered but i probably wouldn't die for
that cause
i would die for the pro-life cost
because that's how deeply it matters to
me and i know that every other pro-lifer
feels the same
so that's just an example to show how
much the so the quote-unquote social
issues actually matter
the social issues fueling the virginia
race are less about abortion and more
about parental rights now the media will
say that the debate is about education
and it is
but this isn't some dry back and forth
over education policy
these are parents who want to protect
their children from being indoctrinated
into the far left cults of critical race
theory and gender ideology
the battle over education of virginia is
very much a cultural battle
it's a culture war obama's right about
that
it's just not the kind of culture war
that he wants to have
democrats would rather not discuss
indoctrinations in the schools at all
for good reason
terry mcauliffe has been fumbling the
issue spectacularly for weeks
first saying out loud that parents
shouldn't decide what their kids are
taught and now most recently admitting
that there are some issues with
education but then he intentionally
misses the point about what those issues
really are listen
i make the point that we've got to do a
better
job in our education system we've got to
go back k to 6.
early on we've got to start teaching
talking about these issues much earlier
than we've done it before and we don't
do a good job in our education system
talking about diversity inclusion
openness and so forth we don't we've got
our textbooks but you know there has to
be a big part of how
how do you fit in into the social work
of our nation in our fabric how is it
that we deal with one another is to me
is as important as you know your math
class your english class and so forth
and we don't
yes the education system is failing to
teach diversity and inclusion terry says
meanwhile the parents rallying at school
boards in the state feel exactly the
opposite about it the school spent
entirely too much time imposing their
twisted ideas of diversity and inclusion
onto their students we don't want to
live in a culture guided by leftist
notions of diversity and inclusion
the kind of inclusion that includes boys
and girls bathrooms for example
that's why mcauliffe would prefer to
just not talk about these issues at all
democrats would much rather indoctrinate
your children quietly induct them into
leftist ranks without anyone noticing
while never having to defend the
practice much less defend the ideas that
they're foisting on our kids
yonkin is perhaps on his way to a once
improbable victory precisely because
he's forcing democrats to talk about the
things
they don't want to talk about
so who is canceled today
i hope we could say that establishment
republicanism which shies away from
cultural battles and social issues in
favor of issues nobody really cares
about is cancelled should have been
cancelled long ago
recent events not just in virginia but
across the country
should i would hope put a final nail in
its coffin
and that'll do it for us today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021.
a democrat gubernatorial candidate says
diversity and inclusion is as important
to a student's education as math and
english class a yale epidemiologist
encourages parents to pull their kids
out of school rather than making them
take the fouchy algae and dave chappelle
refuses to cower to the woke mob check
it out on the michael knoll show
[Music]